[Music]
how is everybody doing that's what I
like to hear well for those you don't
know I'm Val staples the Event Director
for powercon I'm so happy so many of you
are here today we have a very special
panel today and I know a lot of you are
confused as to what this panel is about
well I'm kind of confusing myself and
I'm eager to find out but I'm not the
one to tell you about it instead let me
introduce to you the one and only Kevin
Smith
hey folks thank you for coming out
number one give it up for bow man
without him there is no power Kong thank
you for being here this is my first
power Con certainly not my first
convention period but my first power Con
and a delight to be here you can feel
the fervency I've spoken to a lot of
people the passion is there it's and
it's really inspiring but I just want to
share a quick thing that had happened to
me and didn't happen to me it wasn't a
bad thing it was a great thing on the
sales floor
not only are we here to talk to Rob
today and whatnot and honor him for his
work but also like I came to shop as
well so before we got started I was like
do we have time to go shop sells for
sale animation ink archive is one of the
companies that's down there so went
through and picked out a bunch of cells
me and my friends and the dude who runs
the booth one of the two dudes who run
the booth was like here man look at this
one here and you know it's cells of
animation from the show and the you know
I guess in some cases viewed through the
eyes of of perverts
these cells could be suggestive in some
way so when it was pointed out to me
because I would never see it through
these eyes I was I was raised Catholic
for heaven's sakes so when I looked at
the cells suddenly I saw it and I was
like oh I guess I know what you mean
he's like we're doing a whole series of
these and I was like what do you mean
he's like we found every cell because
they've got all the cells from the
Filmation archive they're like we went
through all the cells we found all the
cells that are remotely suggestive and
we're gonna put him under a series
called 50 shades of grey skull
I said you sir are a professional comedy
writer absolutely lovely to be here
ladies and gentlemen I am a big John
roof fan a big obviously DC Marvel
Universe fan but the MOTU universe as
well or masters in the universe is right
alongside with it unfortunately it came
right after I stopped collecting toys
and when I say stop collecting toys my
mother told me were 14 no more toys so I
watched my friends buy the toys but I
was fully engaged with the cartoon you
know because I was an after school kid
and whatnot so I'm well versed in in the
lore but I'll be honest with you I don't
hold a candle to anyone in this room and
particularly to Val and his friends I've
been working on some stuff that like
they've been incredible resources on man
this thing that Rob's working on as well
so without further ado we should
probably talk about that rather than me
sit up here and talk about my bona fides
I want to talk about another guy who
who's been carrying the the flag if you
will for the franchise for a long time
and Mattel as you know the home of Eman
and masters in universe there's a great
team of folks over there who are really
interested in like keeping it alive and
and and thriving and going and stuff and
Rob did that in the pages of infinity
war and that's what we're gonna talk
about today so welcome to this
Sageman the great rob david everybody
hello hello how long have you been at
Mattel at this point 75 years no no I
have been there for eight years and when
you got there were you well versed in
he-man and Masters of the Universe
I yeah I mean I was a fan growing up I
played with all the toys I got into it
through the box art which is which is
what floored me first and drew me in and
I learned to write I think by playing
with the figures and being like he-man
and when I got to Mattel I've told the
story actually told us about it 40
minutes ago but they gave me all the
Bibles for every show that ever come out
beforehand and I read them all and then
I realized that you guys are the
unofficial Bible of the of the brand
just reading all the stuff that you guys
say online that's what really informed
me what was the idea behind the DC
series that you did it was it like hey
man we just got to keep this in the
public eye or do you have a story that
you wanted to tell I had a story I want
to tell I wanted I really wanted to tell
a story that grounded all the characters
we knew and loved and progressed them I
wanted to tell the story we wouldn't we
were waiting for and I wanted to you
know do things where you took someone
like Prince Adam and you explored what
who Adam was in relation to he-man and
what if there was no Adam what would he
man be then and what if Skeletor got the
power and what's the destiny of Teela I
wanted to all of the factions to come
together and tell a big our own Ragnarok
you know before there was a major motion
picture Ragnarok you know that kind of a
story to move the ball forward and
really satisfy things that we remember
from the original how do you get Adams
voice down in print it's one thing when
you're watching the show you know
clearly the actor could have inflected
whatnot but how do you get it down on
the page because that was one of the
things I really liked like you know it's
not gonna say it's easy to nail he-man
because that sounds dirtier than I meant
it but it's it's it's it's it's you know
harder to grab Adam because Adam
represents us when we sit down and watch
the show we want to see the heroics but
Adam is our way in how do you and how do
you handle that in this day and age is
much easier when he would watch the show
because everything is like moral yeah
oriented but like when you're just kind
of like I'm just gonna tell a story were
at no point during my story to the
characters have to turn to the camera
explain the moral of the story like how
do you write the hero at that yeah I
think with Adam he's okay he's he's
tough also because he's usually that
he's the he's the center of the circus
in a way he's like there and everybody
else around him gets to be wacky and
wild and crazy and kooky and he's more
of the kind of like the straight man and
but I think what makes him so special is
that he's he's us he's all of us he's
you know he is you know you look at him
on the surface and you would you
wouldn't think much of him necessarily
aside from the fact that he was born a
prince which is not a bad thing to
happen to somebody but he really is is
unassuming you wouldn't think that he's
the most powerful man in the universe
and that's kind of the the point of the
whole thing that he really does have the
power just like all of us really do
inside have the power so you he's really
embracing the fact that he is the the
entry point of view character he's a
little bit of Peter Parker a little bit
of Steve Rogers a little bit of Billy
Batson and all Adam what what when it
went out there in the world like anybody
creates something you always get a
little nervous how people are going to
respond to a particularly something that
has a fan base that's been around for as
long as the mo - fan base what kind of
reaction did you get did you find you
were welcomed or did you find people
being like you don't know he-man I mean
I think it was a growing process I mean
I think
I think what fans don't mind new
exploration so long as they feel that
you know the core and you respect the
core you know it's like you got to know
the rule before you dare to break it and
I think I was so benefited from you know
getting to know you guys and I think you
knew that that we were doing this with
with love you know it's we love these
characters so much so much that we want
to see them progress and grow and I
think that the fact is as long as you're
you honor the core it's always fun to
explore the possibilities and I think
fans embrace that it's just such a rich
tapestry in terms of its mythology in
terms of the history of the show
everyone talks about now in the business
like IP and and like I want something
that everybody knows something that it's
existed this is something that has like
a turnkey universe to it just like how
you know one day Marvel figured it out
and turned down their Cinematic Universe
DC took them a minute but they turned on
something as well everything finds its
time and and I think when you pointed
out Ragnarok you're absolutely right
because when I remember watching that
two things went through my head was like
Oh Flash Gordon the movie and he-man the
Masters universe like it you could after
that movie there's no excuse why you
couldn't like have it enter the
mainstream and that's and I know there
was the the Mike young series which like
I enjoy it as well but is there what do
you think like they can't do like a
current day Masters of the Universe
animated series like wouldn't be badass
if you could do like a series that like
honors the classic era really just picks
up with a classic era left off like so
so that it felt like a continuation
almost yeah yeah I don't know actually
pretty damn cool it would just seem like
a no-brainer because there's a world of
content out there everyone's looking to
do something yeah I mean they're I mean
everybody's getting their their chance
to sing their song it seems like I mean
everyone's got ash I mean there was
there's ant-man got a movie for goodness
sakes you got to you got to movies I can
i I know look if I've is about as close
as I'll ever get to the throne so I
could I could pitch to you like for like
a you represent Mattel I'm not
pressuring you in as much as like if
it's a bad idea it's a bad idea but like
if I had a good enough idea would you
take it seriously all right it's kinda
like being proposed to in public
all right whole thing's in black and
white no different it's bold you'll just
make the characters pop more you know
what I'm saying um no here if I was
gonna do like a modern-day masters
Universe cartoon I I'm like I'm a purist
so I would want to I would want to do
like the the episodes they didn't do
that I like always hope they would like
he's you know man
Skeletor there was never one so I was
like man Skeletor came close you know
what I'm saying like and every time I
watch the track yeah but but not but
like wouldn't have been bad as if like
he got way closer like what if what if
like this is my dream okay I don't I'm
not saying like take this and make it
dark I don't think you have to make some
of the dark to make it modern or new but
I think you can tell a story with
masters the universe that felt like the
be-all end-all story felt like almost
the conclusion to the classic era Phil
Phil's like give them give us the story
we always wanted to see yes and then see
where we can go from there yes but in
order to do that one would have to have
like a pretty amazing partner because
you
don't have a channel of your own do you
know it's like we need some type of a
streaming service like a nest pod player
does anyone well the thing is masters
universe when I was a kid and when we
were all younger was available like at
the drop of a hat like after school
generally speaking and stuff we knew
where we could find it but it's a
different world now I wouldn't even know
what network that that was on like what
it was back in the day so I wouldn't
even know how to find it so you'd have
to send people to a place that's
different man not like TV something
better than TV no not so much
HBO some other place I think
back powercon here would be my wish I
wish to God that we could do like a
masters Universe series at Netflix there
I said well there's really two things I
mean I I'm gonna go out on a limb right
here and just say as far as Mattel is
concerned that rocks and that that's an
instant green light and if we could get
another green light from somebody else
maybe who might be sitting in front of
me who's probably really embarrassed
right now that would be really really
cool teddy is Sally from Netflix if we
pitch you this idea
with
wait oh my god
oh my god now I'm I'm I'm no lawyer but
I believe this is legally binding if
there's anybody in this world who can
grant this wish
it's teddy man teddy we really feel like
Netflix is the place for masters theater
verse so much so that well we did it we
put a little something together but the
only thing to summon it we're all gonna
say have to say hold our swords aloft
and say the magic words so I want to
just repeat after me by the power of
Grayskull now we not I we have the power
[Applause]
there you go
ladies and gentlemen original Netflix
anime series Masters of the Universe
revelation this is bringing brought to
you by the good folks at Mattel and the
good folks at Netflix and the good folks
who they've allowed us to put together
on a little team to do the show shall we
yeah I mean this is a Netflix original
series original anime series produced by
Mattel television kevin is I'm proud to
announce is the showrunner executive
producer
thank you thank you
well remembering please remembering
temper this I did make yoga hosers so
let's hope for the best
yeah ladies and gentlemen the really
nice thing is we get to have fun and
play and in the MOTU sandbox and stuff
but I'll be honest with you the good
folks here at power con have made it
largely responsible in in many ways Val
and his friends in Amman org have
created an invaluable resource that me
and the writers have been tapping on a
regular basis fandom has kept this alive
and fandom is gonna feed the thing we're
not making something that's like we're
reimagining it through the prism of the
guy that made Mallrats not at all not at
all we are honoring what has gone before
man and everybody on this team feels
that way it's the purest thing you're
gonna see next to what you used to watch
when you were a kid man we're gonna give
you the thing the episodes that you
always wanted to see and I've seen the
outline we've been working on it for a
while I've seen character designs we
have amazing stuff planned for you man
it's really really cool
I just want to put it I want to echo
what Kevin saying and put in the context
masters is back okay it is a we've been
we've been talking about this for for
many years now and and what it means to
raise the big tent of this franchise the
tent is rising okay
we have I see a few tents rising I mean
there'll be no jokes like that in the
show I swear this could be all me ah all
the time I swear but just the spirit of
this this is you know you know we have a
major movie that we're doing with Sony
where we're going to be honoring what
you remember but also trying to reach
the next generation of kids and then we
have what I'm so excited about with this
which is the love letter to the show we
grew up on and what I think is amazing
about what Kevin is bringing to this is
two things respect to the material you
know when I when I first met you we were
you know you were my first choice to
work on with this and to to show run
this and and I remember going to your
house for the first time to try to get
you you know well you had all the best
toys yeah and and you know and Kevin
knew the material and he's and he's a
fan of the genre and and in every single
time I I've worked with you and every
single time you know more and more and
more he's got the encyclopedia with like
post-it notes and everything and to the
point where now he's frankly starting to
scare me a little bit with his depth and
he's like neo and the matrix where he's
like I know kung foo right he just knows
knows this and knows the characters and
which leaves me the second thing which
is I think having you bring so much
humanity to it there the the carrot it's
so character driven so emotional like
all of your your work like chasing Amy
it always has such such a beating heart
to it and the characters are always the
most important thing and you're really
going to see that delivered in this
story that is that's because the source
Tyrael laid it out for as such laid it
out for us as such there is plenty of
action of course and when we're writing
our scripts we're working with fantastic
team of animators the good folks at
powerhouse animation give it up for a
man they did Castlevania they painted
this poster beautiful the good folks at
powerhouse told us when we were right
when writing our scripts they were like
look don't worry about the action stuff
like that's what we live to do so in
your script just take care of all the
character and all the relationship stuff
and then when you want something
exciting to happen just write fighty
fighty and I have had the best time
writing fighty fighty and not having to
figure out generally you like Payne
steak over every line going like all
right well beast man punches he-man
first and then he-man flips me and then
these guys like don't write any of that
just write fighty fighty so now we write
these really intense interpersonal
connection scenes cuz that's kind of
what the show was fighting fighting a
man yes yes and then yeah if I be
fighting but it is it's the foundation
is relationships and that is kind of
like my wheelhouse so it's it's I love
the action stuff we do in the show and
I'm sure the good folks of power house
will make it look amazing
but I'm really most thrilled about like
the character interplay we got going on
so far the relationships we got going on
really honours the source material and
feels like a continuation that's one of
the things I liked about this show and
one of the things I like about most
entertainment I like whether it be like
the flash or Supergirl keyman I like
characters that like each other I like
that they get along I like that they're
family I like that they're friends
there's warmth there so we lean into
that in a big bad way in revelation
that's a great point because I mean you
said it before you know it's not just
dark you know it's not we're not just
going for something dark and brooding
and gritty but that doesn't mean there's
not drama and stakes I mean it is if the
stakes have never been higher but
there's still humor and warm
and these characters genuinely love and
care for each other and and that's why
you care about what happens to them
and we got real human beings behind the
show not just us as well can we show
them the writers yeah hey man let me
introduce you to the folks with whom I'm
gonna be telling we're gonna be telling
this story come on up real quick Tim
Eric dia and Mark join us up here if you
will
[Applause]
and then do we have the powerhouse boys
where the powerhouse boys come on up
Brad
Melanie and Kenny come on Melanie get on
up here we're gonna get you up here you
watch this is the team ladies and
gentlemen these are the faces the human
beings behind the storytelling
we had a great writers room we've had a
great time working together everyone
pulled together a fantastic story that
we feel well it's certainly excited
Mattel and whatnot but none of this
happens none of this boo sorry
really goes anywhere without Teddy man
like Teddy is all of you who's been
going since the beginning keeping the
flame alive
this whole event is meant to embarrass
Teddy's yeah basically no like honestly
like the I've been in the business now
25 years and and mostly in my end of the
business and stuff which is no business
whatsoever but sometimes I go into the
mainstream world and so I've dealt with
mainstream folks and in corporate world
and whatnot and I've never met anyone
like Teddy he made us so excited to work
on something we were and excited to work
on and you know how like you always see
something that somebody takes from your
childhood and adapts and you'll see a
trailer and you're like oh my lord it's
gonna be everything and then you ghost
pay to see you like screwed again like
that's because there's generally some
exact somewhere who's like thinks
they're smarter than the source material
like wow you don't need this like that's
that's in the comics or that's in the
cartoon you should change it to this in
setting we found somebody who represents
the entire audience
every time we throw an idea out there he
can yay or nay and stuff based on being
a part of this audience and knowing what
the audience wants so when you hear
about stuff like hey they're taking
something I've always loved and they're
gonna do it again or something like that
they're rebooting it or there's
equalizing it or they're taking it
further moving the ball sometimes you
based on history your right to be like I
don't know if they're gonna get it in
terms of this project that we're all
working on it will never step off the
path because the world's biggest he-man
fan is at the helm the whole thing
exists the reason that we're going to
Netflix is because it's heady man so
that's all the way
[Applause]
that is all a great way of saying that
like if you don't like what you see the
person to look up is Teddy now you know
some people have been waiting for a long
time for this and some people don't even
know how much they're gonna love this
until they discover it and whatnot but
you rarely ever get to see the
instigator the face of what puts a thing
in motion let's get them up here give it
up for Teddy man come on up here man
show your face come on this is the face
of fandom right here
I think we could all say stuff but I
honestly feel like you should hear a
little bit from the man himself man
because my lord he loves it you're gonna
talk you I'm telling you when he sat
there with us in the writers room my
heart soared you don't get execs like
this every day or any day and these cats
will tell you as well
most cat most execs most people are like
I don't know that sounds dumb or on a
make it cheap this guy was so not that
guy this guy was excited he was on the
floor and crawling forward talking about
what if what if Cringer did that you
know and [ __ ] like that
so it was astounding at a great creative
thing to be part of like we weren't just
handed the reins and said figure it out
and come back to us one when you're done
like the person who instigated it all
came to our meetings had input and
whatnot and his input was good like
legit great ideas
every time we sat there I'd be like
thousand legit good idea and then I
stopped being surprised after the first
like 20 minutes because he was a gold
mine so he lives and breathes he men
there's a very embarrassing photo of him
wearing a Snuggie that all the writers
pass around amongst ourselves they won't
we don't have anything oh it's beautiful
any time we're down at any time for
sitting they're gone like are we doing
the right thing we just say do it for
him and so give it up for teddy man
Teddy say so
[Music]
this is my seventh powercon I came to
the first one when we were at the LAX
Sheridan four point Sheridan lax I met
so many wonderful people
MOTU is my number one everybody
everybody has their number one whether
it's Batman or spider-man whatever
masters has always been my number one
when Rob Rob and I just sort of somebody
said you really need to meet Rob David
like you really you should get to know
that guy and we did and we had one of
the best breakfasts I've ever had with
somebody in in a comparable position
everybody he whatever he said just now
it's not true it really it's this entire
run and Rob is just as much a part of
this if not more so we had I mean this
is the rob David panel we had one of the
best breakfast ever
and we just kept talking and we just
kept saying man I wish we could just
what do we got to do to get our
companies to want to do this and and I
said alright let me go back let me let
me try to work on my in and you try to
work on your end and let's just see if
we can move this ball forward and and
then and then I had this unceremonious
meeting with Brad and we just started I
said hey it's like Masters of the
Universe and Brad was like he's like I
got this Jude loves it and nice like I
said the Rob hey what about powerhouse
and it just started to slowly do and
then Rob said what about Kevin Smith and
I went you're never gonna get him sure
go ahead go try go ahead like I was like
that's great idea never gonna happen
Rob is like we got Kevin Smith I was
astounded I was like I was like like
like legit like like he wants to do a
he-man quarter so then we go back to
Netflix we're like hey we're gonna do
this with Kevin Smith and they're like
really okay we need a press release we
have to do that like then it then it all
became real and then we hired this team
these people are real writers they're
real writers they're good I've read them
I've
I heard them they're good writers I'll
let these guys introduce them but there
this is this is the team this is it give
it up for Terry
we'll we'll go to the writers next but
let's hit powerhouse cuz they're on
their feet right now Brad what do you
want to tell him about what this thing
feel look like man they did Castlevania
give it up for these kids
so at powerhouse we're pretty well known
for the fight choreography type stuff
that we do fighting fighting and so one
thing growing up with masters we always
wanted to see the fights that we weren't
quite allowed to see you know the actual
swordplay and the beating through giant
walls and all that other sort of stuff
and getting the opportunity to show the
godlike powers of the Masters of the
Universe it's just something we really
really wanted to do so what we're trying
to do is get all the imaginary scenes
that you had playing with the figures as
a kid and get that box art to come to
life and really do it the way that the
fans have always wanted it done
[Applause]
Tim tell them where you came from before
this uh man I came from watching a lot
of he-man and the Masters of the
Universe as a kid I wrote a movie called
reign of the supermen that came out
earlier this year and and thank you and
I just have to since you know I don't
you're not gonna say it I had this is
our first chance to work together I've
never worked for somebody who works as
hard and is so talented Kevin Smith well
they're outdated but but others good you
you it's an inspiration and it is a joy
to work with you you are classic hi I'm
Eric I have worked with a person who
works as Hardin is wonderful as Kevin
Smith it was Kevin Smith I worked with
him on Supergirl a whole big bunch and
when he transformed into he-man here he
pointed his sword at me and Cringer
became battle cat I'm really just
Kevin's Cringer yeah I was scared but
now I'm really excited to go into this
with you guys he's less Cringer less
Cringer and more battle cat Eric wrote
like the if he ever saw any of the
episodes of Supergirl that I did he
wrote like the best ones he's fantastic
so we were lucky to get both him and Tim
D yeah
I just got off like I ended it on a
Friday I started this on a Monday Magic
the Gathering also for Netflix I could I
could also say I really loved he-man
along with everyone on this stage but I
also really like you guys because during
writing I've been watching a lot of
YouTube unboxing videos for like the
really intricate details and everyone
catches all of them and I've been
watching like pixel Dan
[Applause]
I won't tell you which ones I've been
watching ya D have wept with poor Marcos
tell me your shirt story man
dia took this so seriously she cooked
assured that what the picture was yeah
it came in the mail some of that 50
shades of grey skull this one it was two
sizes too big so I washed it twice and I
boiled it which you can shrink a shirt
boiling it and now I bit she boiled the
shirt for you people give it up for mr.
mark barnard in is my co-host on a
podcast called fat man Beyond and we've
been teasing this for a few weeks go my
lord give me your bona fides where do
you come from let's see I just came off
of a show called carnival row for Amazon
and then before that Treadstone and then
before that Castlerock and then before
that
Alfa's and then before that playing like
interchanging that legs on my he-man
dolls to make sure that like the various
colors of the rainbow all got to be on
the bottom of he-man but yeah that's
what I've been up to me the these are
the folks that are pulling together what
you're gonna see and we can't give out
too many details about what that is
would you like to see a little teaser
story
[Applause]
it's all good with teddy until there's
an unapproved document and then suddenly
everything goes up a radical return to
Eternia ladies and gentlemen revelation
is a direct sequel series to the classic
era of Masters of the Universe
featuring fan favorites he-man Orko
Cringer and man-at-arms the story pits
our heroic warriors and guardians of
Castle Grayskull against Skeletor evil
in beast man and the vile legions of
snake Mountain but after a ferocious
final battle forever fractures Eternia
spoilers it's up to Teela to solve the
mystery of the missing sword of power in
a race against time to prevent the end
of the universe
her journey will uncover the secrets of
Grayskull at last this is the epic
he-man and the Masters of the Universe
saga fans have waited 35 years to see
and we have a full obviously or the
characters were playing with but we've
got of course many more characters to
play with throughout the universe and
they all come to play as well well
stink or making a big stink or plays
hopefully you'll be there cut it off and
take a big selfie of everybody also I am
playing me man not all right we're gonna
take a big picture with all y'all behind
us so maybe you got stand up we can turn
the lights on so we can see them and
stuff and we're gonna selfie it up we're
trying to selfie it up somebody's gonna
photo yeah I don't know how it's gonna
do we're gonna have to punch in the hold
on one sec don't anybody leave
[Music]
[Applause]
well done ladies and gentlemen I think
do you have anything else you gotta get
I really I'm so ecstatic to be able to
share this with you guys and it's such a
labor of love and I just want to say
again that all of the passion that you
guys have invested and feel for this
material over the last 35 years you guys
have been carrying the torch and now I
really want to say we're kicking off
he-man masters of universe is back and
Mattel is 1,000% committed to unlocking
the full potential of all of these
characters from the from the origin
lines of the new figures that are coming
out the fall of 2020 to the movie with
Sony to Kevin Smith working on a massive
revelation and more more more to come
that we will be back to tell you about
sometime soon
this is it guys the moment we waiting
for masters is back
that is all we got real ladies and
gentlemen but finally in closing thank
you all for being here thanks for making
the time and stuff by the power of
Grayskull have a great power Con
you
you